die neue woche beginnt für die alte
geendet hat mit dramatischen nachrichten
am freitag schüsse in saarbrücken ein
rentner schießt auf polizisten heute
schüsse in nordhessen in einem
supermarkt
sie schreit noch um hilfe dann wird die
frau von einem zur stunde noch
unbekannten mann erschossen so geschehen
in diesen aldi supermarkt in
schwalmstadt nordhessen laut zeugen soll
ein mann beobachtet worden sein wie er
zwischen den regalen eine frau verfolgt
sie schreit laut um hilfe der verfolger
soll dann sie und danach sich selbst
erschossen haben
fehlt eine 53 jährige erschossen die
polizei ist binnen weniger minuten mit
zahlreichen kräften vor ort und sperrt
das gebiet um den markt ab die kunden in
dem supermarkt sind schockiert von der
bluttat sie hatten erst gar nicht
verstanden was passiert bislang ist
unklar in welchem verhältnis täter und
opfer stehen die polizei geht aber eher
von einem privaten motiv aus und nicht
von einem amoklauf
und jonas einander ist für uns vor ort
in schwalmstadt jonathan was kannst du
uns zu der aktuellen situation sagen
thomas sind gespenstische szenen hier
vor dem aldi in treysa da stehen auch
die einkäufe die sind nicht
abgeholt worden da steht noch alles auf
den auf den kassen bändern das zeigt wie
fluchtartig hier die menschen die ganze
szenerie verlassen haben denn diese frau
ist hier eingerannt hat um hilfe
geschrien und niemand will das so
richtig bemerkt haben so sind die
zeugenaussagen die halten das alles
nicht für echt die haben gedacht dass da
eine glasflasche zersplittert worden sei
als diese waffe getätigt haben muss
näheres wird uns jetzt die
spurensicherung hier die hinter mir zu
gange ist sagen können im laufe des
tages die ermittlungen laufen auf
hochtouren denn auch das ist nicht klar
ob es bei der tat sich um eine
beziehungstat handelt oder ob es
womöglich andere hintergründe zu der tat
gibt was die polizei allerdings
ausschließen kann ist dass es dritte
also dass es andere beteiligte bei der
tat bis jetzt gibt was weiß man über die
beiden personen
über die beiden weiß man noch gar nichts
es gibt inoffizielle meldungen darüber
dass die staatsanwaltschaft marburg
mittlerweile das haus des schützen des
mörders
also erkannt hat und dass das da jetzt
weitere untersuchungen stattfinden aber
da wird weiter untersucht und daher
laufen die ermittlungen auf hochtouren
vielen dank jonathan anders